a ring depicting the head of an antelope
a pendant showing a tattooed hand
holding a coy with pink sapphire and
diamond rings adorning the fingers
details that are often only apparent at
second glance auto yeah Cobbs creations
are full of humor and illusions like
these earrings which like all of his
works come with a certain vibe should
hide its emission placenta for me
jewelry is only beautiful if it has a
vibe to it fun and this vibe is often
caused by a disturbance that's still
there there's nothing worse than beauty
that is too slick when I saw blood give
birth to Turner's auto Yakov is
self-taught he made jewelry by copying
the techniques of the old Etruscans and
the Celts cultures which had fascinated
him since childhood today 10 employees
helped him realize his designs they work
with unconventional materials like ebony
and tropical seeds which they mix with
gold and gemstones hit the vahana
kindness on a few felt I probably
wouldn't have such a variety if I didn't
love so many different materials I'll
get a longing for a certain material and
then I'll work with it until I've had
enough nope I'm done then I'll often
feel the need to work with a completely
different material for deafness magnum
I'm not often that the odds of it before
auto yaqoub began making jewelry he
started painting under Georg ballots but
he didn't find it fulfilling and began
pouring his creative energy into making
jewelry
the Goldsmith created this lapel pin for
Georg vacillates who became his first
paying customer other commissions
followed including this one for York
Inman Dorf the late contemporary artists
even made a painting for auto yaqoob it
shows Imman Dorf himself on the Tower of
Babel the golden hand represents the
goldsmith he had the hell not a fluke oh
I had the luck the great luck not only
to know these artists but they also
started wanting my works the gunman so I
had the honor of working for them which
naturally was a great motivation for me
to Albert went to Disney hosts IVA
LaShawn does Phil McGraw I couldn't just
produce any old thing for them it had to
be something significant you could say
that was how I got started I think the
unfun man Albert now he's enjoyed two
decades of success and his creations
find buyers worldwide auto yeah cogs
pieces of jewelry are like little works
of art they tell stories which are often
full of symbolism there also veritable
treasures which can cost up to a quarter
of a million euros this Linda is equal
the decorative jewelry is the worst it's
a terrible concept just a hollow shell
there's nothing behind it Danny he
thought the unmet and tightness I always
aim to create content that enrich is my
life II my label icon
many of you Colts works are inspired by
nature where he finds interesting shapes
that can be transformed into jewelry the
results may be earrings shaped like
leaves or beetles happy in debate case
Ted went out I went out into the world
got ideas and have been doing this ever
since it is unfair or my work is simply
a necessity for me but Wendy Gator see
Albert also Yakult continues to follow
his own calling creating jewelry that's
both striking and fanciful